Let me play this. This is hilarious that Marvel did this. I love Marvel,
but dude, once people's, here's the thing I don't like.
Here's what I don't like about twins. When they,
when they have an agenda,
any time I can sniff an agenda in anything I'm out, dude.
Woo. I'm out, man. I'm out that. If I'm going to go skydiving,
if I'm going to go watch people skydiving and I'm just along for the ride in the
plane and I'm just chilling and I don't have a pack on. And I'm like, well,
I would never jump out of a plane.
I just wanted to make sure that you guys were all safe and was here to document
it. And then they go like this. Okay, cool.
And start talking like there's an agenda. I say, give me the pack. I'm out.
And I jump out, dude. I hate agendas. I don't like him. That's why,
whenever you sniff something like, it's look, it's fine, dude. I get it.
You want to have, uh, all the equal opportunity and all the. And like, you know,
you should have all the different kinds of colors and every show is fine.
Looking like a F a McDonald's commercial. I get it.
Put a guy in a wheelchair in it. That's fine.
But the second you put too many guys in a wheelchair in a show.
Or the second I sniff that a guy was cast because he
wasn't white. The second I get that, bro,
I'm turning on something else just because I don't want to sniff the agenda,
make it real.
This is.
Best of that right here. This tweet is from Lilith. I love it.
The first non-binary superhero in Marvel and they named them snowflake. No,
this is not fake.
And then this is the thing I've watched snowflake and safe space. R
I I, there's two.
One's named snowflake and one's name, safe space. First of all,
let me just tell you right now, that's worse than Batman and captain America.
That's worse than cool names because those names are for.
Who wants someone to save your life? You want, you want,
uh, uh, Marvel.
What's the girl who didn't like when she was going through TSA.
Cause the guy fester a guy to hit on her. What's her name? Marvel head.
What's her name? Brie Larson. What, what the did she play?
Captain Marvel, Marvel head. I don't give a. Whatever she played.
That name is cooler than Hey,
help, help. Don't worry.
safe spaces here. No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I want the human torch. He's got fire. Look at this.
Also two white guys created this.
Snowflake and safe space are the twins and their names are very similar to
it's this idea that these are terms that get thrown around on the internet.
Yeah, no.
We've heard them.
That they don't see as a derogatory.
I mean, okay.
There's no super hero with the, with the N word. You know what I mean?
There's no superhero with any racial slur for a reason.
So let's not take anything derogatory and make it a positive.
Cause it gun get in trouble.
That's just right for the picking. That's a farmer going trouble.
It's so easy.
Don't do that. Now look.
Those words and kind of wear them as badges of honor.
This guy doesn't even believe it. You know, he's just like, I don't know.
I got 40 grand for making this. These.
They told me to make them androgynous and I maybe Brown.
So I just did it look at this white guy,
just like I'm getting in trouble for this. Probably aren't I getting in trouble.
Saves face, dude trying. Oh wow. I love it.
You can get in so much trouble for trying to help.
This Avanir safe space is kind of a big burly sort of stereotypical
jock. He can create force,
but he can only trigger them if he's protecting somebody else.
Okay. I get it.
Hopefully. Cause non-binary then goes by. Snowflake is non-binary and.
But further snowflake is non binary. Um, he doesn't have a or a. She, he,
she does. He or she, he is not, she,
I don't know whether to call her he or she because he or she doesn't exist. Uh,
there is no Cocker on him or her and a bone structure is androgynous.
You can't tell.
Has the power to generate individual crystallized, snowflake shaped SRE.
Kim's the connotation.
You know, caller called or some snowflake, dude.
I would love it in the first issue.
They just got just mowed down with guns.
You know the word snowflake in AR and then they'd just drive away and go Trump
nation. What's your name? Snowflake.
Forcefield say space.
Yes.
Right now are something fragile.
And this is a character who is, uh,
turning it into something sharp.
I think it would have to that music in the background of boring to make it more
interesting. Listen to that. It's like, it's like,
it's like something that would be in like a nineties movie where a guy was
picking a safe, it's always that music that they do with boring.
I hate that. I don't like that. I used to not, I made a movie when I directed,
I wrote and directed a movie it's called almost when I was 23 years old.
Nobody knows about that. And it's a straight up drama dude,
because your boy serious is. I'm serious as I'll get out. Okay.
I made it and it went to one film festival and as good as. All right.
And you can't find it anywhere and that's fine.
It wasn't even about showing people to me.
It was about making it and the process. I loved it. All right.
Anyway, um,
I put no music in the movie because I'm so sick.
It's so annoying when people you ever watched Grey's anatomy and it's like,
what are we going to do? [inaudible]
[inaudible]
we got them [inaudible] Oh, Oh, we got a code red limp bump bump. Oh,
but it's okay. Oh, here comes his wife. Oh, she's frumpy. Give me back.
My husband. [inaudible]
all that. Just make it the show, man. Although the music in that show,
the outsider is tripping. It's so good. Anyway, here we go.
And uh, this is a character who is, uh,
turning it into something sharp.
Snowflake is the person has the more offensive power and safe spaces.
So out of the book, it's offensive. It's a more offensive power
just using all these budworm buzzwords, right?
More defensive powers.
The idea was that they would mirror each other and compliment each other
snowflake and safe space.
It's just wonderful. It's so wonderful. And I don't say wonderful,
but it's so wonderful that they thought this was a good idea that this is where
we're at in 2020 that they thought that this was a good idea to do this two
white guys and the biggest funky company in the world.
And then also.
[Inaudible].
Let's see these tweets here waiting for this.
This is a parody. It has to be. There's no way. This is,
this is something that will be on SNL. Like they would come to save the day.
They'd be like.
Become safe space. And they're like, no, but really help me. I'm dying.
And he's like, well, I just want.
To make sure you're not offended.
Somebody wrote Robert writes,
are they still in denial?
That the people they are trying to pander to don't buy comics.
And then someone writes back to him just because they won't talk to your sweaty
at the comic store. Doesn't mean they're not buying Bobert.
That's funny actually. Um, Oh,
this is hilarious. Some guy wrote safe spaces.
Arch-nemesis will be a villain called reality. Wow. That's funny. Good job.
Moon Bob. Good job. Moon Bob six. Um, yeah, but do it like just,
just chill.